The joe rogan experience.
I'll tell you what,
we bring up a lot.
I hope I haven't overdone it in the shows,
but I'm fascinated by this idea that we're never going to go backwards.
Yes.
You know,
when you talk about,
you know,
this modern world and you look around and you think,
okay,
basically since the renaissance,
it's been all,
this is the stock market.
We've been going up ever since the renaissance and the idea that everybody has
is that,
and we're never going to go backwards.
We're never going to go look at a thousand years from now and see people who
don't know about DNA sequencing anymore.
It's planet of the apes,
right,
where you've gone backwards and Oh,
the statue of Liberty's partly buried in the sand.
And I mean we,
we,
but every other culture,
every other country in the civilization,
in the history of the world has thought that.
I mean,
you didn't think the Romans were thinking,
God,
it's great.
Now pity it can't last.
Yeah.
But we learned from them.
We know,
maybe we can not just that maybe the whole globalization of the fact that
everybody's connected.
We'll change that dynamic.
But I think if you're gonna,
if you're trying to learn from history one thing,
history shows us these stock market upticks in the civilization stock market
don't last.
So what does that,
well,
we like to think we're more special than all the other animals first and
foremost.
So we would like to think that,
you know,
even me,
I'm guilty of this guilty,
absolutely as charged.
We'd like to think that we are eventually going to cheese,
achieve the highest levels of understanding and that that's the trend that
things are going and eventually going to work everything out.
And we won't have war someday in the future.
And that somehow or another,
we are basically human beings are basically good and uh,
we're going to work this out in the universe is going to reward that.
But I got one word,
the one word that refutes that.
Dinosaurs.
Okay.
The whole world was fucking run by Conti,
heartless lizards,
cold blooded monsters without a fucking Spec of emotion that never wrote a
fucking thing down,
didn't give a shit about culture,
would eat their babies,
would eat anything that stood still.
That's what dominated this earth for the longest time,
and if it wasn't for an asteroid impact,
very likely would still be a version of that animal still running shit.
Bad cops.
Fucking Ed Asner.
Yeah,
exactly.
Bad Cop shows or one of my favorite things of all time,
so much so that there was a show called Della Ventura.
I remembered the name of my manager also manages Kevin James,
who's a the king of Queens.
Right.
And they were on the same network as Danny Aiello when he had this show called
Delavan.
Tara and I had them get me the tapes because that you couldn't find them.
I have I trailer the original master
tapes,
great show.
It's horrible and awesome at the same time.
I cherish these tapes.
I have people over for Delavan tour watching parties,
and I'm not walking around bump them over to a digital.
I have to do that.
I'm sorry.
It's so bad.
It's so awesome.
Only get so many runs on the tape so you to you gotta transfer that should not,
haven't watched them in years.
I'll over transfer.
I can.
I have them like in a sacred spot.
Have candles around them and make sure it keeps him safe.
I thought it'd be a really good idea to buy first season,
macgyver DVD box set.
I was like,
fuck where you're at a meeting dollars.
Let me tell you about macgyver.
Macgyver is infinitely better than Delavan.
I mean,
it's not measurable.
Dell inventory is one of the worst shows the world has ever known.
That's where man beats up every young punk that crosses his eye.
He's the best at everything he does or the grants.
Marino fucking you will drown in Danny Aiello Ego.
You will drown.
You will never make it out alive.
She was good and do the right thing so well.
He's an amazing listener,
right?
No bullshit.
I don't know who made the script.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
That show.
I'm talking about shitty.
I'm talking shit.
Maybe Danny thought it was a subtle comedy,
but he's an amazing actor.
There's no,
you can't take that away from them.
The Guy,
he's an incredible actor and so of course he has a bit of an ego.
He's,
he's,
he's fucking bad ass.
He's a bad ass actor,
but still,
that show was so bad.
It hurt your feelings.
It was.
It was so bad.
You would watch it and go,
Holy Shit.
Like he plays,
he plays pool with this guy,
this young punk,
and he fucking shoots in every ball and the guy goes,
you're the best I've ever seen.
Mr. What's your secret?
He goes,
my secret,
don't miss.
It's the best,
worst show ever.
This fall in a fetal position and,
and break your own fingers because you screwed.
See them so tightly,
so embarrassed for him.
Let me tell you about the first season.
The episodes,
I don't know.
There's had two seasons I think.
I think he went to see,
they might have been just one season.
I'm not sure.
I have a nice box of them.
The first season of macgyver to watch it.
It's three quarters voiceover.
I don't random jungle shots like helicopter over the jug with like,
and then I broke him out of prison.
It's like him.
No Way.
Next voiceover
bullshit thing really that bad.
They could have shot the entire thing are seasoned and about four days.
What if,
okay,
let's say,
uh,
I don't know anything about your personal situation,
but it's,
let's say you're in love.
You're found the girl.
This is the one you want to marry.
Okay.
And you have the opportunity for one day or one hour,
let's say an hour to feel what it's like for you to fuck her and she gets to
feel what it's like to be you having sex with her so you,
you feel what it's like to be her getting fucked by you and she feels what it's
like for you to fuck her.
We think you could do that.
Do you think you could lie there and get fucked by yourself?
I don't think I could handle an hour.
I don't think I can handle it.
Our of what I'm dealing with.
There's nothing you could do that.
Do you think you could deal with like kissing you and do you think you'd love
her enough to let her be you for an hour and you'd be her?
I really love myself so I'm pretty sure that if I got fucked by me and if I was
a chick for an hour,
I'd probably really enjoy it.
I'd probably be,
if I was,
if I was a check,
I'd probably be a squirter.
Do you think you'd give up the booty?
What'd you go anal.
Would I give it a check and just taking the ask from yourself?
Well for me,
yeah.
I mean I'm yourself.
Yeah.
You spit on your hand or writing around solar analogy back and open it up wide
for you.
I don't Dunno if I should go ask them out for yourself.
That's the real quick question.
How much do you really love yourself?
Because you probably don't love yourself enough to go after ass to mouth on
yourself.
Fuck.
But if you watch porn,
girls who don't even love guys are willing to go ask to mouth.
Right?
So consider,
well,
the [inaudible] are getting like 2000 bucks.
So do I hope for two thousand five thousand to fuck myself?
If that's all it takes for you to go ask him mouth,
we can have that arranged
the way it has to be fucking upset,
right?
Yep.
We'll just make a mask.
We just make a mask.
It
would just make a mass that looks just like you.
It's not gay.
If it's yourself,
how about we make them bass looks just like you and we put it on a girl with a
strap on.
So it is like you're fucking yourself.
Not Enough.
No,
definitely not.
You need to be the girl.
I need to actually be a girl.
Because then you'd say,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm not even me.
I'm hurting.
You look down,
you see your penis and you go,
oh no,
no.
I'm still a guy.
That's a fuck on a game I play.
I know.
I'm so confused.
I don't know whether I would fuck this thing or I wouldn't.
I don't know what's me and what's not.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Itunes or recording to server the fuck outta here.
Server.